we are with a very happy Victor of
today's round Christopher you
back-to-back victories for you
Christopher uh big victory it wasn't
easy tell us a bit about this game
I really didn't know what was going on
like most of the game I felt like I
would just
playing off like intuition but
in fact at some point like after Knight
C5 I really panicked
um Knight to C5 uh I think on move
all the way here 22 was yes Knight to C5
at this point looking at your B3 squares
it's not looking pretty yeah
but then I had this extremely lucky
trick where I sacked my work
when Knight E takes C4
and I think Knight to B3 was the move uh
recommended at this point did you see
this move and what was your uh response
the following response for you I think
my plan was Queen B2 then Knight D6 and
if I take this Knight takes C4 and now I
take back 96 now I take it Bishop D6 oh
Knight to C2
B6 B6 and just play it like this yeah
and you have enough compensation and I
do believe that this was actually the
correct response as well you did have
enough compensation here
um but after Bishop to G2 it does seem
like you're starting to take over the
initiative where was the The Rook
exchange that you mentioned
Knight to B3 Rook sacrifice
um yeah this was kind of the work
sacrifice but I I found it amusing how
all these pieces were somehow like
hanging it's almost it's so it's a it's
almost like some it's almost like
somebody decided to just randomly put
the pieces on all the all the most
hanging squares it's like so unfortunate
for him yes yes you play Queen B2 Knight
A1 Everything is hanging the Knight on
B4 is hanging the bishop on this is
attacking that Knight on B3 Bishop on G2
and you're only a piece down
that's not bad but like here if you if
you count the material I'm officially
like a like a rook and a piece down yes
but somehow my position somehow it's
still a good position just because how
unfortunately his pieces are placed and
you're actually going to be upon up at
the end of all this melee because still
one Rook under attack as well as his uh
two pieces Knight on A1 and which one G2
very nicely calculated Christopher
Bishop takes a rook to C1 and it felt
after this that you just transitioned
very precisely into a winning position
two out of two in the last couple of
games after a rough start did that
feeling of disrespect fuel you into this
round as well
I think I think I maybe could have
worded it better I felt like
the interview might have been a bit
disrespectful but I wouldn't say I
personally felt disrespected by it got
it got it now that clears the cobwebs
for us uh definitely Chris Christopher
congratulations still a huge victory for
you and plenty of games yes left in the
tournament guys
question from Anastasia yes I was just
wondering how much time Christopher
spent in social media yesterday after
that interview he got many many comments
even from top players like Anish giri
answered to his interview like did he is
he aware of those comments and uh what
what he thinks about it yeah I am a I am
aware of the comments I could tell that
there are a lot of people that were on
my side and not on my side and there was
a lot of like controversy behind it
but um
how did it feel to be in the center of
attention is that something that
distracts you at all or
yeah it was it was a little bit
distracting
maybe I maybe I could have been better
prepared if I was if I didn't keep
checking the whole the whole drama and
what other people are saying
and what did your parents uh tell you
because we know that your dad is always
with you always supporting you in every
tournament what did he tell you about my
dad was fine with it but my mom was like
concerned she was like why why is
everybody saying all these bad things
about me and but I I I sort of felt like
I sort of expected it that after I
realized what I said well there's good
things and bad things you have to take
it everything with a grain of salt yeah
thank you Christopher congratulations
big victory for you a nice result and
still plenty of games to go thank you
absolutely congratulations Christopher
and the results are coming in